it's my pleasure now to introduce
shencheng
who's a PhD candidate in computational
neuroscience at the University of
Southern California devised by Professor
Lera et she received her master's degree
in computer science also from USC in her
bachelor's degree in biomedical
engineering from cinco tinkle university
her research interests lie in human
vision computer vision and machine
learning focusing on theory and
applications for both normal and
neurological conditions and today she's
gonna be talking about machine learning
based screening for fetal alcohol
syndrome disorder 1 and thank you for
the introduction thank you for having me
here to present my work we just heard
you exciting applications a applications
in the area of a human health and there
are many other machine learning
applications in the health care area for
example the dip learning pace medical
imaging analysis many of these
applications have been at clinics or
afterwards so what about something
earlier today I'm going to talk about a
machine learning basic training
procedure for a fetal alcohol spectrum
disorder that's one type of
neurodevelopmental disorder so F est is
classified prenatal exposure it's one of
the most prevalent neurodevelopmental
disorders in the North America and
almost the top one in South Africa
children with FS DS show growth
retardation and impairments in the
central nervous system as severe subtype
can show special facial features
ethnicity can place high psychological
pressures in large economic burdens in
areas of healthcare social service
special education which can cost
millions of billions of dollars annually
in United States early screening and
detection is of significant importance
because it can lead to early
intervention and treatment to mitigate
the severity and prevent developing
secondary Combe abilities or
disabilities it is crucial for
neurodevelopmental disorder especially
for FSD because there is no cure for FST
the only thing you can do is early
detection and early in
invention however currently has no
efficient and while I give the screening
tools the clinical diagnostic process
can be time and casas consuming large at
risk a large portion and risk population
cannot have timely diagnosis because of
a limited clinical capacity differently
next can have varied diagnostic criteria
leading to in constancy of treatments
FST also has a hike morbidities with
other neurodevelopmental disorders which
can determine stag gnosis so a screening
tool that is time and cost efficient has
objectivity and unifies genders and can
be easily accessed in popular wise is
desperately needed so here we're trying
to propose a machine-learning screening
procedure that can meet with all of
these challenges and may have
substantial impact of the referrals
system and the diagnostic process so the
first question to ask is what kind of a
test we're going to use given the fact
that the FST can impair structural
cognitive and behavioral aspects of a
human so we're starting from a multi
model perspective which uses six attacks
with english domains of i a moment
controls the kinetic test and neural
imaging so the first of three tests are
called a psychotic a moment ask it's
occurring the rapid a moment where
you're redirecting your phobia to a
visual target the first test is called
Prozac a test where you just direct your
phobia to target and with your other
measurements from this test the accuracy
your performance the accuracy the
variability the main sequence does about
the velocity and the amplitude and other
sensory motor functions such as a
reaction time a second test is called
anti saccade so instead of directing
your thought to what they target you
directed away from the target so besides
the parameters are just mentioned
there's another measurement called
response inhibition because there you
need to inhibit your automatic process
to the visual target the third has a
physical memory guided task
the participant need to remember the two
targets in sequence and then the
inutility Rio Salado till the correct
locations in the correct order so
working memory is also involved in this
test the next test is a for free viewing
so the subject subject is just asked too
freely
so the participant just asked to really
watch a video and we have a camera on
top of spring to to record their eye
moments so from the right of the screen
we can see a lot of dots that are
positions of the subject to record it so
you this test is about your visual
attention so you can direct the Sakura
to some interesting object we call
mastering the object you can also
directly record in a top-down manner
it's called like top-down attentional
modulation so the series objects have
different excellent ABB's aspect we call
them silencer channels it can be color
can be orientation can be the motion so
we completely like the ceilings in maps
along different channels and extract
your eye traces along these maps and to
result in the attentional choices so
these attentional choices will be used
for later analysis the fifth test is
Bala psychometrics so examine the
cognitive and execute functions in areas
of attention memory and academic
abilities the last test is about the
neural imaging we use a different answer
imaging two images a corpus callosum
that's a part in the middle of your
brain connecting the two hemispheres
we're recruiting
relatively large clinical group and also
its age magic typically developing
controls and we have a 22 FST and 24
controls compute all of the six attacks
there's a large experimental setting the
next step is about the classification
for lots of measurements which are
different it has the except of reviewing
because the data are active a low
dimensional so will you say SVN based a
procedure called a recursive future
elimination it's an iterative procedure
and as each iteration what deletes a
least useful feature so after
termination we have a better classifier
together with its corresponding future
groups we do the feature selection and
classification at the same time for free
viewing data we first computer settings
in map and strategy your attention no
traces as I mentioned before and then we
pass the attention no traces is through
a convolutional neural networks because
we have different video clips will have
different to learn the representations
for the attentional choices then we have
another layer of classical classifier to
do the video selection and the final
prediction and after that waited another
module model analysis for the group of
the subjective who finishes all of them
we train a classifier from the outcomes
of the single classifier the final
classifier can be work hi or whatever
happy one here we'll use a lot of detail
regression because we want because it's
easier to train and easy to generalize
so for the during the classification
procedure we are still discovered the
most distinguishing features are related
to the disorder to get your profile
comprehensive profile I should say of
their neural currency or neurobehavioral
at impairments and we can get a better
accuracy with your multi module analysis
and this accuracy about 85% is
comparable to the state of art from for
other
scoring procedures but most of the other
screening procedures use the similar
measurements as what the clinicians use
and the further NASA to show that only
using protocol anti Sakhalin reviewing
and the commercial can result in that
accuracy we study accuracy we can also
evaluate the hazard from different
aspect such as the time is restriction
cost and accessibility the framing
and the prozac had used a list of the
time has a list extraction and cause
this is easy to access so we proposed a
screening procedure here so we just used
the project ID and have every frame work
and if the participant made its
requirement who can add another and has
a car with no extra cost and if we we
need to pay more attention more time on
money we can do a three-step test from
the psychometrics
and such a procedure can provide a car
to be an objective signature of the
disorder from their common TV and
executor function address and the data
can be analyzed through the machine
learning papa was unifies the enders and
much easier to pimp a pen with early and
preschool age children to quantify the
monetary benefits with the run model
from the theory of value of the
information so the CS denote the cost of
the screening for the correct detection
there at the rate of detection rate and
FP PF reversed here the fraction of
patients and the y minus PF refers to a
fraction of control if we have a false
alarm we very classified control at the
FSD and the true and active if the
control is controlled and the messing
read if we miss a one patient and
there's a gang of G that can be denoting
for if we click correctly detect the FST
if it has a little error intervention
there's a casa for the clinical
diagnosis and there's a loss if we
missed one patient and the expected
value can be calculated at the sum of
the probabilities timely outcomes and
for individual case with FSD if we deal
a protocol and the river being screening
annually the expected saving can be over
$7 thousand dollars if we extrapolate
this calculation to our for his next
participant group and if we do the force
that have the screening that the pro and
unethical reviewing in psychometrics the
expected saving can annually can be as
high as over a hundred and eighty seven
thousand dollars so to conclude our
machine learning basic screening
procedure is a high throughput and low
cost it can be widely used target a
target at the
at risk population and celerity clinical
process and little earlier interventions
and treatment which is crucial to
neurodevelopmental disorders at last I
want to acknowledge my collaborators
Angelina Jamison Ducks from Queens
University here in Canada and Po he who
is the former lab member and my allies
Aloha et and also our founders and thank
you in an open to questions thank you
any questions
thank you for your time and your
attention
[Applause]